[Musica]
[Applauso]
sono malleus arrivo da Recanati una
cittadina molto bella illuminata
dall'immensità di Giacomo Leopardi dove
ho questa attività che L'Antica bottega
amanuense e quindi sono una manovese ma
prima di raccontarvi un po' di quello
che che in questa vita sono riuscito a
fare Mi vorrei soffermare su quello che
è l'infanzia e che l'infanzia è stato un
fulcro importantissimo una fucina
straordinaria che mi ha permesso di fare
cose che magari non erano facili e
quindi io ringrazio fortemente la mia
famiglia perché era una famiglia molto
umile non Povera però umile Sicuramente
sì quindi non avevamo giocattoli e noi
la Befana era due mandarini due
ciambelline ma aspettavamo con ansia io
e mio fratello che aveva nei tre anni
più di meglio sei lui 9 Eravamo quattro
fratelli e per andare nella discarica
solida di questo paesino dove prendevamo
tutti i giocattoli che i ricchi del
buttavano via e quindi li portavamo
nella nostra casa gli mettevamo per
terra e poi cominciavamo all'Opera di
smontaggio di questi strumenti di questi
giocattoli per capire se erano
realizzabili una loro riparazione oppure
se non era possibile smontati In parte
quindi una planimetria anche del lavoro
e molle ingranaggi rotelline e
quant'altro Voi capite che ha 6 anni
Questa questo gioco che che era di
questo divertirsi a fare questo
smontaggio e ricostruzione crea nel
bambino una manualità straordinaria
un'inventiva perché devi capire già da
subito Qual è la possibilità di riparare
un giocattolo di farne un altro e così
via e quindi questa questa partenza così
impregnante Di manualità Ed inventiva
poi si si amplia nelle nella andando
avanti con gli anni perché ehm per
aiutare la famiglia d'estate invece che
andare con giocare a pallone andare a
Fiume mi sono fatto un anno con il
fabbro un anno con il falegname un anno
con l'elettricista un anno con il
muratore e ho acquisito questa
sommatoria di mestieri che li trovo
attualmente nelle mani adesso per farvi
capire che vuol dire una manualità vi
faccio vedere una cosa molto simpatica
come vedete la manualità poi si amplia
anche con il fatto di sapere allenarsi
di continuo quindi fare la manuenze
permette di avere questa mano abbastanza
calibrata per scrivere queste cose
allora
il forte è che unendo la manualità la
creatività
l'ingegno la tenacia
è possibile poter mettere insieme una
tal quantità di doni perché sono doni
indubbiamente i ce ne sono dei delle
cose acquisite che ti diventano un dono
e ti permettono di poter avere quella
accortezza per passare da un sogno da
un'idea a realizzare il definitivo
l'aspetto finale
il raggiungimento dell'obiettivo è una
cosa abbastanza difficile ma la
sommatoria di queste cose ti portano ad
avere questa possibilità Diciamo che io
poi vado avanti diventa un musicista
compositore sono sei strumenti
con coraggio e Credetemi un po' contro
tutti e quindi deve nascere ritorna ero
direttore di una fabbrica
mi metto sull'idea di costruire il primo
studio di registrazione delle Marche non
c'era nulla si andava a Milano Roma e in
pratica
successo istantaneo clamoroso perché non
c'era nulla quindi tutti i musicisti
delle Marche ma anche delle regioni
limitrofe hanno cominciato a frequentare
il mio studio perché hanno la
possibilità di poter non mettere giù
provini pezzi e quant'altro si faceva
poi passo a spostarmi quindi parto dal
bacino di Fabriano un paesino molto
piccolo ma straordinario a livello
medievale mi sposto a Recanati quindi
questo una città molto più grande il
comune mi mette a disposizione questa
villa con Loreto molto bella e da lì
ampio l'attività Dalle prime otto piste
a 16 piste e quindi praticamente porto
questa professionalità ancora più estesa
Poi però ci fu un evento non so se
quanti se lo ricordano
1988 ci fu una crisi abbastanza
devastante che
fermò la discografia la rase al suolo
praticamente da quella volta non si è
più rialzata Quindi abbiamo tre quattro
casi discografiche in croce e io ebbi un
problema anch'io di lavoro unitamente
alla banca che comunque ti ci mette
sempre qualcosa sulle spalle e poi
abbiamo una tragedia familiare molto
molto forte perché morì mio fratello E
allora quando ti trovi di fronte a
queste soluzioni della vita che ti porta
certe realtà
Senti che sei di fronte a un bivio
quindi non puoi andare a chiedere a tuo
fratello a tuo papà il sacerdote
all'amico quello che devo fare vedete
Questo è lo stemma araldico che sta
montato nella o del Castello sulla sulla
parte esterna C'è scritto
Cerca la verità dentro di te quando sei
di fronte a queste realtà della
che devi fermare
e poi devi trovare con una tua chiamata
una tua domanda quello che devi fare ti
arriva se tu chiedi la vita ti da sempre
una risposta quindi mi sono rinchiuso
questi dieci giorni non eremo e da lì
poi lo posso raccontare perché è un po'
lunga ma però da lì è venuta l'immagine
filmica di quello che avrei dovuto fare
e quindi io appassionato di calligrafia
Perché scrivevo già bene nelle scuole
elementari con il pennino l'inchiostro
decido di dopo che state forte visione
avuta in questo momento di meditazione
torno e decido di aprire questa bottega
altro momento assolutamente forte contro
tutti quindi lì la tenacia è stata
decisiva perché è uno dice ma come in
questo momento di grande tecnologia le
prime stampanti i primi plotter e i
primi Macintosh no che se li ricorda i
telefoni grandi così uno torna da un
aereo e dice cosa ti sei fumato sulle
eremo Perché tu vuoi tornare adesso e
aprire una bottega di scrittura a mano
no è stata una cosa molto molto vissuta
molto forte e ora mi sono detto vabbè se
mi arriva un segno dalla vita
comincio perché la vita rimanga sempre
dei segni L'importante è saperli
osservare se non mi arriva nessun segno
mi aspetto un po' perdere tempo a tutti
ma poi comincerò Comunque questo mio
amico poi ve la racconterò molto
brevemente è tornato un viaggio due anni
che non ci vedevamo Mi porta un regalo
senza sapere niente Era la prima penna a
punta piatta degli amanuensi con cui si
possono fare queste cose e quindi da lì
sono partito io quindi ho cominciato a
questa attività chiaramente
addestrandomi e formandomi con i
maggiori Maestri emanuenze del pianeta
Quindi da lì si passa a tutte le
scritture celtiche gotiche che
genereresche e così via insomma E fondo
la mia la mia bottega
formando uno dopo uno tutti i miei
allievi e attualmente sono 10 che
lavorano con me siamo il più grande
scrittorium che c'è in tutta Europa
insomma forse anche nel mondo e questo
ci permette di poter capire un
successivo passaggio cioè stavamo in
questa villa cinquecentesca ma eravamo
costretti allora mia moglie che mi ha
molto
sempre suggerito cose importanti è stato
mio un mio partner molto Straordinario
con suggerimenti sempre molto Giusti
come le donne fanno e cominciamo a
cercare un luogo più grande per fare
questo questo questo questa nuova
bottega questo nuovo laboratorio
due anni di ricerca senza riuscire a
trovare una soluzione tra ville
palazzi difficili da poter gestire e
quant'altro
cinque anni Prima che decido questa cosa
in un viaggio a Torino mi addormento su
un pullman a Rimini Sud e faccio un
sogno lucidissimo dove vedo una cosa
straordinaria che poi oggi riesco a
capire quella fisica quantistica quello
che è successo Insomma vedo una cosa
straordinaria mi sveglio a Rimini Nord
appunto subito sulla sulla carta i
disegni perché sono molto veloci a
perdersi e praticamente dopo 5 anni
prima non riuscendo a trovare
un luogo idoneo per fare la nuova sede
metto con la predisposizione di
realizzare questa cosa qui e quindi
Costruisco da zero quello che era il
sogno Cioè io praticamente ho visto
questa questa
questo castello nel dettaglio Infatti
non cerchi detto c'è soltanto
l'ingegnere che ha praticamente fatto i
calcoli strutturali perché siamo in zona
sismiche e quant'altro Ecco qui in
questo castello noi abbiamo il nostro la
nostra attività dove è tutto comfort
Tenete conto che se vogliamo costruire
un castello bisogna Innanzitutto trovare
una sorgente di energia come le
cattedrali non ti costruiscono così in
qualsiasi parte quindi io un po' lento
individuata La Sorgente dell'energia Poi
però devi costruirla applicando le
tecniche della geometria sacra
altrimenti non avrebbe senso e quindi
l'applicazione delle tecniche
geometriche Sarra ha permesso di
realizzare trovare una struttura dove
c'è una un aspetto di equilibrio perché
si parla della sezione aurea quindi un
aspetto anche di qualità della vita di
energie interne che si si sommano e
questo permette di avere un luogo
bellissimo dove pace e creatività sono
il nostro fulcro principale in cui noi
riusciamo a fare questo lavoro Insomma
poi è stato orientato a 21 gradi est
perché poi il sole passa sempre sopra
quindi ci permette di avere una
luminosità costante come tutti quanti
scrittorium che sono quella latitudine
Chiaramente la via formazione di
plurimestieri che ho nelle mani e sono
anche perito chimico ci ha permesso di
di realizzare anche
l'accorgimenti per la nostra bottega
tipo
stavo raccontando che ho realizzato un
inchiostro che prima dell'anno mille è
talmente tenace stando in tema di questa
sera che se per caso ti sposti un dito
Durante quello che stai facendo lo
porterai per 10-15 giorni Diciamo che
non va via quindi il bello Ovvio di
riprendere un'attività che stava
scomparendo il bello di formare persone
portandole al silenzio e su questo La
Mondadori mi ha commissionato un libro
che si chiama scrittorium che ha venduto
molto anche negli Stati Uniti e in
Inghilterra dove la calligrafia diventa
la parte di Fermo della persona di
introspezione cioè quando uno scrive che
non ha fatto mai delle cose prima il
cervello si ferma ci sarà quella
sensazione di pace di benessere che poi
è quella che ti scrive si accorge di
avere
Diciamo che la mia parte musicale non si
è mai fermata comunque perché fermare la
musica sarebbe molto grave e quindi io
ho composto quest'opera che si chiama
opera totale
che è un brano unico di 50 minuti e poi
nel 96
ho lanciato questa idea nuova che non
era stata mai fatta prima è attualmente
sono arrivato a 41 concerti che il primo
concerto multisensoriale audio olfattivo
praticamente le persone vengono portate
in stato di rilassamento si chiudono gli
occhi un impianto audio straordinario
diffonde questo questa musica surround e
contemporaneamente arrivano gli odori
della musica
i profumi della musica che sottolineano
questo viaggio interiore che che vive
questa esperienza riesce a fare e
arrivare a 41 concerti Poi fermati Lotto
di di marzo il momento di covid con
telefonate continue per sapere se
riprendo e perché un'esperienza non
raccontabile che la chi l'ha vissuta
che non si può applaudire alla fine
arrivo in punta di piedi e
perché
riporto le persone che sono nel viaggio
nello stato di di realtà e qualcuno
tarda venire poi io ho l'abbraccio della
folla che piange commosso chi ti
racconta quello che ha visto chi non può
parlare perché è molto emozionato
Comunque la parte emozionale è molto
molto forte Insomma sulla parte
emozionale ci sarebbe molto da
raccontare perché è la linea conduttrice
dal sogno alla realtà
se non ci fosse questa linea conduttrice
emotiva Praticamente il il sogno il
desiderio rimane in pratica sospeso
fermo e non riesce a portarsi a termine
quindi ci sarebbe da approfondire questo
aspetto dell'emozione qui Sono nel mio
sulla torre del mio castello dove In
pratica passo molte ore del giorno a
studiare a fare cose nuove a contattare
le persone che mi chiamano e così via e
quindi se volete fare una passeggiata
poi alle Canarie è diventato un punto di
riferimento turistico Vi aspetto molto
volentieri
[Applauso]